[Musik]
wir haben es installiert Leute ich kann
mich in alles verwandeln ich kann mich
sogar in den Enderdrachen verwandeln ich
tue jetzt so als wä ich ein Schwein mal
schauen ob Sandra mich
schlägt Alter was will denn das Schwein
jetzt von mir sorry hab gerade ganz
kurzen Kampf mit einem Schwein Leute ich
werde das jetzt immer mal wieder ab und
zu machen Dschungel dürfen uns jetzt
nicht verlieren ne ich finde dich nicht
Sandy dann sei doch auch nicht so
schnell was für schnell machen was mal
mit dem Esel Leute ich Anfang Dschungel
kann ich dir nur sagen Anfang vom
Dschungel was siehst du denn um dich rum
ist da irgendwo Bäume
irgendwelche Monster Tiere irgendwelche
Blöcke ich sehe halt Lianen undten
Esel Leute ich werde das jetzt erstmal
ganz lowy fahren das serwg ich denke
diese Mops treten ja einfach so
auf
[Musik]
h
lucao bist du okay ich mach Papagei ich
mach
Papagei
selfie ja ich bin hier
oben ich weiß nicht wo du
[Musik]
bist siehst du diesen großen ich bau
mich kurz hoch dann siehst du mich wie
kann die den Papagei nicht sehen wie
kann die so Papageien nicht sehen hat
die das gar nicht gejuckt dass hier ein
Papagei war ja die Sache ist hier vorne
ist die Perle weiter geflogen aber die
ist halt kaputt gegangen deswegen ich
will jetzt nicht mehr so viele schmeißen
Leute wie viele muss man jetzt wohl noch
schmeißen weil wenn die Richtung sich
jetzt schon so drastisch verändert hat
soll ich noch eine
schmeißen schmeiß Meinung zu wie hieß
der Fußballer Marcel Eris wo spielt denn
der Marcel eres kennst du nicht
nee
ich werfe jetzt mal hier noch eine
[Musik]
hin nach unten wie die ist einfach nur
nach unten geflogen die ist hier nach
unten geflogen ja dann müssen wir hier
runter komm 2 Jahre später leute seht
ihr
das seht ihr das Leute hier vorne ist
das Ende Handy wo hier das ist der
Eingang soll ich da mal rein ja müssen
wir ja
wohl du kleiner Hohn die du mal da vorne
um die Ecke schau einmal hier ich habe
keine Glühlampen scheiße da müssen wir
noch mal kurz raus wir brauchen Kohle
mist ich will mich gleich auf jeden Fall
noch mal verwandeln aber ich weiß nicht
in was und ich weiß nicht welchen Moment
das kann do nicht sein oder
Tür
ja Bau du mal kurz die Tür da ab ich
schau noch mal kurz hier
oben kom
[Musik]
hochgelaufen kurz Kuh und akzeptiert
vollkommen D Kuh ist und einfach weiter
s ich ganz kurz gegen die vitrineer
jetzt die Perle okay Leute ich wer eine
Perle wenn die mir jetzt nicht den
verdammten Dings zeigt den verdammten
Weg zu diesem
[Musik]
idiotenportal da lang wo lang wo lang da
lang hinter dir
da wo ist die Perle denn die ist hier
hingflogen ich sehe gar nicht diger die
Leute haben doch wieder keine Ahnung im
Chat die schreiben immer irgendein
schwachsin die sagten auch schon ja mit
dem Schwert drot das eher die ist
durchgeflogen durch die Wand was ein
Schwachsinn ihr habt gar keinen Plan die
zeigen nur den Stronghold wir hören
jetzt nicht mehr auf den Chat alles ist
blöd Männer alles dumme arschlcker los
wir teilen uns jetzt auf alles was ich
jetzt so zubaue ne da brauchst du gar
nicht jetzt reingucken okay geh du mal
in die Richtung da hinten ich schaue
hier okay ich bin ein Skelett Leute ich
verpisse mich komplett hier ist nichts
ne ich glaub wir wurden auch
gescammt ich glaube auch hast
du was hier ist SOP was ist eine
eisenperson eine Person ist hier wie wir
die geht gerade runter jetzt oh mein
Gott wo wo ist sie das ist der Endboss
wo Leute das war kein Skelett der hatte
keinen Bogen wo
denn ganz unten da ja der ist
weggelaufen aber der ist nach unten
gelaufen Laa der sah aus wie du aber der
hatte kein Gesicht und kein nam Leute
wenn s das nächste mal irgendwie sowas
sieht dann dann schickt mir das mal oder
macht mal ein Screenshot so ich ma jetzt
noch einmal high speed hier durchlaufen
Sandy in alle Richtungen du
auch wo bist du
denn hier wenn ich weiß nicht wo du bist
ich lauf hier unten irgendwo in der
Bibliothek her ja runter hier vorne ist
ein Dings ist hier ist auch ein Boot was
ein Boot ja scheiß mal auf Boot nein ein
riesenboot ich weiß nicht wo du bist Bau
dich mal runter zu mir hier ist einfach
ein Boot
ja
ich was laberst
du s komm mal zu mir hol mich jetzt mal
ab ich bin hier unten
oben was ist
das jand auf dem
Boot du kleiner Wicher du
kleiner
hä wurde von concraftter mit Kai flaube
erschossen wie geht denn das du hast
mich gerade erschossen du warst auf
diesem unsichtbaren Boot und eine krcke
ist vor mir wo bist du
jetzt wo bist denn du ich bin da wo du
gestorben bist Check sie wieder nicht
die checkt nicht das ich die dass ich
der Frosch bin sy siehst du den Frosch
ja schau mal zum Frosch ich bin neben
dem
Frosch guck mal wer da ist
hä hast du dich als Frosch verkleidet
junge du
K bisschen parano hab das mitbekommen am
Arsch ich bin jetzt raus ja ich bin auch
raus okay lass uns aber auf jeden Fall
noch einmal schnell nach oben bauen dass
wir den nächsten Stream nicht unten
beginnen obwohl doch wir müssen das Ende
finden wir müssen hier auslogen ja Danke
schön an Lein King das ist ein Mod von
von mein Mod hier der hat das ja alles
programmiert sehr sehr lachkick dieser
prank heute konnt wir S auf jeden Fall
wi mit prank ich GLB das Youtube Video
wird richtig geil ein schönes WE wir
sehen uns die Tage wieder oder Check
einand hat Sandy hat es geklappt was
hast du gecheckt als was ich mich
verkleidet habe okay du warst der Frosch
ja und du warst Skelett ne ja Skelett
war ich auch was war ich noch die Kuh
das Schwein das verfolgt hat ja ja das
war's nee ich war noch
mehr ich war noch das Boot ich war im
Dschungel der Esel und weißt du noch als
du dich daanz ganz hoch gebaut hast im
Dschungel dann war auf einmal ein
Papagei neben dir ja ich war der PAP ja
gar nicht gerollt schön und jetzt
verpiss Dich junge ich leg jetzt auf
Ciao
[Musik]
Leute
y